another treatment senior John Legend is
taking that next step after marriage
he's about to become a dad so is John
ready you know let's just say that he's
got a few things to learn before their
baby girl was born can you change a
diaper yet I'm going to learn their due
in a couple of months and while John
seems pretty even-keeled about it all
looks like Chrissy's relishing every
moment of her pregnancy my belly's
bigger than my but it's hard not to
crush on this couple just take a look at
Chrissy's adorable social media posts in
the kitchen together or just chilling at
home with the pups there in the middle
of remodeling their new 14 million
dollar five-bedroom 8 bathroom Beverly
Hills home that once belonged to Rihanna
we're trying to get the house ready
before the baby gets here I don't know
if we're gonna get done in time are you
nervous to have a little girl no I'm not
1 i'm not one of those people that's
like whoa my boy can do anything he
wants and then my girls gotta you know
be in the content just be good people
John's latest project has him teaming up
with acts collective offering aspiring
musicians and filmmakers the opportunity
of a lifetime you have the chance to be
mentored by me and to be featured and an
event at South by Southwest or the
toronto international film fest we're
all about finding all those different
individuals out there who are expressing
themselves in a unique way but his
toughest job right now just might be
choosing a baby name all of your animals
have a P name right yes so are you
thinking about name in the mail well we
all know we're almost avoiding p because
of all of our dogs have peed ain't no be
for the baby yeah i'm gonna say no p
you